[Music]
lifetime achievement award sponsored by
Cavanaugh Holmes bill moody for nearly
40 years bill has been involved in
promoting managing and coaching squash
and making the sport accessible to the
Newton Abbot community his greatest
achievement is his unwavering dedication
to junior squash 2016 saw bill's 30th
anniversary of being involved in the NA
STC junior section he first became
involved in 1986 running the Saturday
jr. mornings and has been turning up
ever since at the age of 83 bill could
still be seen taking on the juniors at
doubles showing off some of his skills
only in the last year has he actually
hung up his racket Phil started managing
one of the senior teams before starting
club nights to promote squash for all
abilities in an informal and social
environment club nights continued to be
a regular weekly feature at the club and
Bill still turns up to help run the show
Janice and Mike Hindle Jamison Mike
Hindle met as teenagers when they were
both members of Epson and Yul Harriers
they moved to Devon in 1975 and in 1991
after their son showed an interest in
athletics they joined Newton Abbot
Athletic Club where by 93 94 they both
become involved with coaching
officiating team management and
administration they also joined the
committee which they're still part of
today with Mike appointed as club
president and Janice in the role of
membership secretary their love and
passion for athletics is clear for all
to see and the time they've given up for
the people of Newton Abbot is
considerable there is a wide spectrum of
abilities at the club and they make
everyone feel welcome pam terrell 39
years ago pam set up the club which is
known today as king Stainton swimming
club and she soon had a lot of interest
from eager youngsters all wanting to
learn how to swim over the years pam has
devoted all of her spare time to
teaching youngsters to swim she also
feels inclusion is the key to all
ensuring that the club is accessible to
those with more complex needs in a world
that continues to place pressures on the
young people of today Pam provides many
youngsters with a real sense of
belonging encouraging the older members
of the club to teach others she's
inspired so many people over the many
years and she open
in you to inspire many more for years to
come
[Music]
you